stay focused team black I should
probably learn more about the Alvin
counter gambit and maybe you'll get to
see me struggle along in these games
here struggle along III you know you
want to play III there and fall for the
Lasker trap maybe it's not happening in
fact if it does I need to change my
settings said it earlier yes I did
what's the move here
mmm
I think this is it put pressure on this
pond is this beep on going to devote
itself to the defense of the c-4 pond if
it does I don't have to worry about my
knight on c6 position as much do you
know why because sometimes there's this
idea of a 3 and b four okay there's I
believe some success with this move
right here by devoting the beep on I
don't have to worry about 83 be for the
night getting kicked away Queen here I
do have to take into account pressure
against this pond and now I'm in a
position to reinforce it so this is a
this pond right here in short is a giant
pest to the white side has to be it's
got to be a giant pest can't can't push
push here so easily there's always maybe
this or even a CAPTCHA timely capture or
even a bishop check still leaning on the
leaning on thoughts of the Lasker trap
now if Bishop g2 might i do should i do
this should i do f6 go for just rapid
development I think I like this let's go
here should be in pre move mode right
there Bishop check would just be met
with night here so I don't know that
that would really be any big deal all
right let's go and now maybe Bishop here
or just
maybe I shouldn't do this chat or this
move because of eventual a 3 B 4 stuff
later so I just go with this right now I
like this idea let's get rid of that
light square Bishop and I'm going to try
and attack the White King when keep in
mind we are on opposite sides here this
is something I just kind of uh I was
actually reviewing this and i was
playing this against a GM the other day
like just yesterday and so I felt the
need to like review this with the
computer certain lines and that's kind
of one of the things that one of the
conclusions I drew about putting
pressure on c4 if the Pawn decides to
defend it you'd have to worry about the
night being kicked around as much that
does show up in many lines John you know
maybe Bishop here to see three can be a
good idea I'm going to try this if a 30
minute I think I'm going to do this and
I really just want to follow up next
with rook here and I think it's still
very uncomfortable to deal with the
pressure that I have in fact maybe
there's no let's say King side attack
but they're certainly pressure against
this pond it is in some sense backwards
and maybe I shouldn't have done this
move Bishop here takes takes the night
runs home actually it shouldn't
whoa the bishop can't be captured I say
all right the bishop can't be captured
otherwise I get that I get the Queen
this is a lot of pressure I have on the
D file mmm um so just looking to
complete my development my nights are
developed classically this is still a
little bit of an awkward placement I
don't know that this night has a good
answer to the now what test the two word
now what test not so sure about that
what does he really do i believe i just
have to cash in at this point yeah okay
let's do that let's get my pieces going
here this rook is finally playing in now
there's gonna have to be a defending
maybe I could get in a 6g 5g for and
kick this night away or is there a way
to just play this and allow the capture
something seems a bit off what's doing
that however maybe there's like Queen
here getting the Queen to a better spot
and then pawn push pawn push yeah this
is like a mini lesson for me in pawn
moves because if I do h 6 i'm doing that
specifically just to advance here but
after age three i would really like to
get this move in okay so now i think i
just back up right here and now g5 will
come with tempo okay so g5 i did I
played my queen here so I could get in
g5 and then if h 3 h 5 g for being the
main idea so I think this night is going
a bit astray I have my pieces on good
squares I am down upon but it's hard to
imagine that white is
feeling like they're they're up upon
here with the pressure now that's a that
is a big move right there that is a big
big decision interesting well this pond
now is past should I however capture
here this is a four-on-two majority if I
don't capture I could play my night here
and then look four Forks I could push
forward it's past and then jump my night
into this Square and of those choices I
think I like that one best I don't know
how crazy these ponds could be getting I
do like and night jumping in here and
then even here I might want to kick this
night away if it plays here okay right
here being the time to do just that
actually not just yet because the night
would land a fork well isn't that a pain
yes it is okay maybe I should back up
right here so that oh no I can't I can't
even do this move my nights would be
unprotected there should i should have
done it in a different way maybe woke up
that was a slip knot a mouse slip that
was I mean a mistake I want to be able
to kick this night away it is in my
territory I don't like this this is
uncomfortable however hang on I do have
maybe Knight takes pawn here and then
Mike wink take this night so maybe I
still do have something going on here
oh now it's just a free pond no matter
how you look at it that's a free I
thought it's typing oh man tyne pressure
yessuh kid ah they resigned yes as a
pretty significant time difference right
there okay good game yeah I think um
what do I think here okay let's see
Albin counter gambit d for you don't
want to do III you know why if you don't
there's a video playing right now
youtube.com / chest network Lasker trap
in short something to be aware of III
Bishop b4 make sure III is already step
as I said a step in the wrong direction
and I explain why in that video so
anyhow Knight f3 night out g3 this is a
line b 3 I think this right here is a
spot that there's a somebody could have
an adjustment here on the white side I
think you could be fairly bothersome to
black by running forward with an a3 and
b4 idea then then this night can no
longer rely upon the c6 square as much
ok so maybe be three instead of that how
about night here maybe that's an
adjustment is that where your night
ended up going anyhow I think it did I
mean just fast-forward real quick ah yes
it did so b3 is a way to save a move in
other words don't do that here night
night to d2 instead is an adjustment a
good adjustment I believe in just in
time I'm there to defend against the
pressure
and I'm just trying to get more
development in with that last move and
trying to get rid of your light square
Bishop tough spot tough spot here I have
pressure on you but this was an
interesting decision to run for with the
night move and then the pawn push I
really don't know who stands better it's
a tough call i have still very dynamic
past pond you have an extra pond i have
a good square from my night he's maybe
not the greatest my rooks are in good
spots tough position good good game good
game to get to get to this point right
here I don't know what would be best if
ok didn't ok can't do that but what I
was thinking of is something how
something like maybe getting your night
to this square I wonder if you can maybe
support your pond even though you do
weaken your second rank and then run
forward with night III to d5 somehow but
I could maybe be moving my knight in
playing c6 but I don't know tough tough
tough game and I don't know if I went
through that quickly this part right
here where I was trying to come up with
the plan to get in this advance I'm
doing it with my queen so that I could
eventually have both my pawns on these
two squares g5 and h5 to eventually get
in g4 ok